ah
well that was a fun little detour
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to poppy
[Music]
playtime game was recommended to me by
lixian so i'm assuming that means that
it's a very good game
and it's going to be a very enjoyable
experience i'm getting wall-e vibes
in addition to
[Music]
oh teletubbies god
that is
horrifying chapter one a tight squeeze
as an ex-employee of playtime co you
finally return to the factory many years
after everybody within
disappeared do i need to know why they
disappeared
is that even important
is that something that i'm going to
discover
am i going to disappear
have i already disappeared you are about
to see
the most incredible doll ever invented
her name is poppy
and she is the first truly intelligent
doll in the world
a little girl can talk to her
poppy gives her answers
she is the first doll actually able to
have a conversation with a child
hard to believe
just watch
[Music]
and she talks like one too hi
my name is poppy i love you
can you help me polish my shoes why of
course poppy just like a real girl poppy
always wants to look her best perfect
thank you
her hair is sturdy and won't come out
when you brush it and smells just like a
poppy flower is there anything else
you'd like to say poppy i'm a real girl
just like you
what's the time
and if you've ever wanted to see how all
of the nation's favorite toys were
created playtime go is now offering
factory tours at just 2.99 a person an
entire hour and the most magical toy
factory on earth
what are you waiting for come visit the
factory
oh
well
i've deduced how the people disappeared
i think it has something to do with
poppy being a real girl everyone thinks
the staff disappeared 10 years ago
we're still here
find
the flower okay
okay sure i'd be happy to
i used to work here after all so
we're like a family oh god
hi
okay
oh yeah
sure okay
lathe pierre closing
oh i see a problem
but i won't mention it
there's other things to explore
hi my name is lee pierre and i'm the
head of innovation here at the playtime
co toy factory if you're seeing this
then you're trespassing yeah we play
this little tape on loop whenever we
close the factory for the day
so trespasser just to make you aware
while we pride ourselves primarily on
our high quality toys and excellent
child care we also pride ourselves on
our security for example this facility
is full of hidden motion triggers which
once set off will turn on the factory's
emergency alarms and directly contact
the authorities and
that's one of the more tame aspects of
our security system no spoilers
so you've got my warning it's not too
late to turn around
i just hope that you're certain whatever
you're doing is worth it
well as ominous and foreboding as your
warning is i'm calling on it
there's no way
eat healthy like brawn what
what that that
what
hell yeah 4 000 calories i love that
ooh hi kitty
nice present
[Music]
boogie bot i love all these things candy
cat oh
just god damn delightful uh oh
that's probably fine okay so you pride
yourself on your security does that mean
that i should probably go to the
security area probably
poppy wants to play
i do not want to play with poppy thank
you very much
[Music]
right
so there's definitely going to be a code
and i bet it's somewhere in here
maybe the train is this green pink
yellow red let's try that green pink
yellow red
hey
i'm a genius i figured that out all by
myself
give me a a brain high five
okay i don't know what that is oh of
course it was blue
the grab
the grab pack
oh
why
only fire at small objects
well that's handy
good great i'm gonna put that to good
use
very good use
i
love this hold down to pull objects i'm
trying
oh
wow
that's
incredible
i love this do i not have a right hand
is this all i got it's all i need but
i'm just wondering if it's all i got
okay can i spider-man my way through
this
interesting
can i hippity hop over this thing
oh yeah oh yeah
oh wait hey
hey
i bet i could have done that at any time
oh no i couldn't
what are you reading what is that hand
that it has a handprint
why
oh my god
i
hate you
so much
oh my god i hate you
i hate you
high five
oh my god i hate you
huggy
power okay
okay never mind i just know
that at some point when i turn around
huggy
is not gonna be there anymore and that's
gonna make me very concerned huggy wuggy
1984 to why why would you put a death
date why would you even imply that there
might be a death date
that's terrible
flight time co has designed hundreds of
distinct toys but none more connected
with the people than huggy woggy our
founder elliot ludwig aimed to create a
toy which could hug you forever forever
is only until the end of your life
technically
as is always true play time co's
four-step process to creating the most
life-like toys was a success
with a bit of string and polyester our
lovable blue pal huggy was brought to
life huggy wuggy has gone on to be
playtime co's most popular and best
telling toy so far
great oh
[Music]
ah
okay
well that's strange
just
this is normal
thanks
thanks for that huggy wonky
thank you
really appreciate it
high five
hey
okay we're fine i'll be oh what is that
what are you what are you
what are you
this place is much oh god
oh god that's blood this place is much
more um
bad looking than the rest of this place
was okay remember do be kind to others
show up on time not hide behind doors to
scare lathe pierre don't stay at past
eight missy's company time tamper with
machinery enter innovation wing without
authorization
okay
i'm going to go in the innovation wing
high voltage
[Music]
there we go
grab to divert power
well i don't exactly have another hand
so i don't know what i can do about that
oh but if i just touch it oh
well now this is just goddamn cool
okay so we got some actual mechanics
ooh
so what did i do
i see
this is really cool
i'm honestly kind of impressed
kind of lagging
[Music]
you there buddy
huggy
oh no
okay
all right huggy
thanks pal
okay cool
that's fine
yum
[Music]
did you guys see that
i'm sure it was nothing
oh my god
no
oh stairway to hell
stairway to bad spelling more like it
all right i'll go down the hallway i
ain't afraid of you
i ain't afraid of you
i'm a big strong brave man
what's happening what is happening
what's happening why is it lagging
we're fine we're all good baby we're all
good
hey
is this the innovation wing
nice
oh nice
it's good is that a doll head
great
okay
all right so i'm looking for a new uh
tape to play
i'm guessing
[Music]
great
huggy says remember to take breaks
sure
breaks longer than 10 minutes are not
permitted sure
okay
oh
do i have
to maybe i don't have to
orange all red okay sure
yeah okay i'll go down
this is probably fine
don't like this door
his handprints sure are handy
hi
okay
got another
one more i think yellow
there we go
okay i got it
and all is good
nothing terrible is happening
okay nothing terrible is happening
nothing terrible has happened yet i
don't know why anyone would be worried
because nothing terrible
oh boy
oh
well thank you for that
didn't exactly deliver it straight to me
but thank you hello
[Music]
i'm fully handed
i don't get this security system it
doesn't make the most sense
but i'm okay with that
because it's so
fascinatingly
odd
hey we oh
hey
oh i need to start somewhere okay
okay
ah
all right
interesting
huh
okay
and we're on the way
i do like that mechanic that is a very
interesting mechanic i've never seen
anything like that
this is very fun
i don't like this conveyor what is that
eyes no eyes not eyes eyes eyes no
not eyes
oh good more
come on
[Music]
yay
oh god where am i oh god
oh
hi
oh hi hello hi
is this the innovation wing
fostering happiness adopt an orphan
today oh that's nice
okay that's that's nice
that seems nice on its surface nobody
leaves without a toy oh
i have to make a toy
good
oh needs power okay make a friend 1960.
our founder elliot ludwig was a
visionary he set the stage for all of
playtime co's greatest feats yet all the
amazing things that he created the make
a friend machine is one of the most
creative impressive and advanced it is
solely responsible for nearly every
playtime
toy sold on the market today all he
needs is to be fed the proper parts and
it will then paint assemble and do a
quality inspection of the toy all in its
own
gone is the need for complex sorting or
back-breaking labor this machine can do
all that
and more
it can break my back
wow
that's amazing i'm guessing they need to
go upstairs
okay
i'm gonna go make a friend
i want to make a friend
i'm gonna make a friend
can't wait to make a friend
huh
oh
ah not gonna trick me on that one what
is that
what is that
oh what did i just get
so stella what made you want to work at
the playtime co factory
playing with joyce when i was young was
so magical
i could go straight for my bedroom floor
to anywhere in the world
it was such a great feeling
and
being able to work at a toy factory
somewhere that can provide kids with
that same experience
that's a pretty great feeling too
sometimes though i really
really wish i could go back
to being a kid i mean
and it's weird cause adults are just
kids but older i don't think anyone ever
really feels like an adult but your body
just gets older and older
and then you die
poof
human bodies just can't stay young
forever
there's things though
like some trees that can stay alive even
while being way older than a person i
mean the oldest people to ever live are
still younger than those
so i guess everyone is always young
relative to something
right
all right i think we're getting a little
off track
yeah a little bit
a little disconcerting that conversation
there but i'm not gonna worry too much
about it i have a circuit to complete i
think
[Music]
this way
then this way
come on yeah
easy
easy i'm a genius
okay but now the toy machine is back
online and i can probably jump down here
and it's fine ow
ow
[Music]
my bones
power on
oh
hi
well this reminds me of ah real monsters
which is a show i haven't thought about
in ages
okay
do i get a friend
ah i see
ah
perfect
i hear one here one there
what friend am i going to get today
i can't wait to see
stop looking at me stop looking at me oh
my god no oh god no
all right pal thank you
can't wait for my friend
why do you look so dead
why do you look
so lifeless
oh hi
can i have you
i have it great what's back here what is
down here
[Music]
i thought it was gonna fall right
through
oh oh oh my god
can i save
i don't know oh oh no
i messed up
oh god damn it oh i mean oh
god damn it all right fine and you're
mine
all mistakes of the past have been
forgotten about and i'm gonna leave here
with a toy
yes
goodbye where to go
is that my toy now do i have that or is
that just not oh
ah
well that was a fun little detour
way my god
i don't think so holy crap
okay oh oh okay okay all right okay all
right okay all right okay
oh my god but i want a hug
i know i can't read that
okay
all right okay i'll get up please don't
start me back okay oh good i'm right
here again
oh good oh my god
it's so good
to see you
god look at you look at me
okay
i shouldn't look at him this is what i
shouldn't do i keep looking don't die
just yet well about that i think i've
done it i think i've done the dying i
believe i'm dead
hog hug hug high five remember when we
high fived remember high five hug
high five okay goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye
what are you gonna oh
well that was fun
oh my god
okay
danger oh oh my god
holy crap
oh my god no this way
i'm jumping across i'm falling down
well how about that
soldier
oh here we are again you know what i
wanted
your gob right in your gob right in your
big dumb gob
run your gob
all right let's uh let's try this again
hello
hi
oh oh my god wait wait wait wait wait
wait i don't remember that i didn't
remember which way to go
well that was a bit of a dick oh
innovation is key thank you science ooh
okay okay this way this way
this way this way right
don't don't what
no no what
we
oh my god which way which way which way
oh my god this way
oh that way no
it's all trick
well this is minorly panic inducing
fairly horrifying
i don't know what all the words oh god
oh god oh god no no god damn it it did
it again
it's such a sack of all right this
time i got this i have it everyone who
doesn't have faith in me needs to buckle
up because it's about to go down
is about to go down
and by go down i mean me i'm gonna go
down in this hole then i'm gonna go the
right directions all the time
all of the times
i know you're gonna do it i know you're
gonna do it again i know i'm ready for
it i'm ready for it this way that way
this way
not that way this way
stop turn back
i will not i'm not going to do that oh
there's a light oh that should have been
a clue
there was a light okay which way this
way
oh my god oh my god where am i where am
i what the hell
hey
hey oh my god
you dill weed
i can't run why am i not running
okay oh my god what is this
where am i
oh my god where am i
what do i do jump
what do i do
oh my god what do we do
what was i supposed to do
was i supposed to do something there oh
i probably was supposed to grab
something i was so busy worrying about
not being where i was supposed to be
that i didn't even think about the
possibility of grabbing something i'm
sorry it's really saying a lot of don't
go forward but i think the only way to
go is forward okay there's gotta be a
grappler right this
perfect
perfect yes
oh my god he's dead dead you're dead
you're dead you're a million ways of
dead
oh
i've done it
i've done it i'm a genius
first try definitely
wow
okay
a lot of red and blue uh
conveyor belts
looks like someone is playing
satisfactory in here
and doing very poorly
hello
ah
okay
convenient
final log in relation experiment 1006
the prototype coordination and
cooperation is evidently within his
skill set
as well as the skill set of all other
experiments of his type
though still missing today's events are
no doubt in relation to him
his absence was a flaw in the scientific
process which should have under no
circumstances been left unaccounted for
that's why i'm making this log
so that the same mistake won't be made
twice
any future experiments will need to be
contained and disposed of in a secure
location
i'm not worried about myself one
breakthrough and i'll be back
we must forge onwards in the name of
science whether those who are beneath us
understand it or not
end of
what
one breakthrough and i'll be back what
the hell does that even mean
what does that even mean who built this
place
what
how can it go on in forever how how can
it do that stop no run danger turn
around go back i will not
be
dissuaded
that's different
this is not what i was expecting
wonderful
wonderful i used to work here do i know
this place
do i know the layout of this
place
is that blood on the floor
okay
[Music]
oh yeah that's it's normal
normal normal
pillows
[Music]
okay
i just like touching things
uh-huh
they're throw pillows great oh yeah this
is ominous
this is quite ominous
that's pretty ominous
poppy
[Music]
hi poppy
how are you
oh my god oh i'm sorry poppy
you opened my case sure did
[Music]
oh wow
all right then that was great for
chapter one um
i think that was really fantastic i
think that's the start of something
pretty incredible i think they've got
really something going on here
i think that's real
nice
scary
a little overly punishing on the death
thing and expectations of reactions
being what they are and uh all that but
i love
i love an
ungodly huge facility
like i love that whole concept like
right from portal and portal to i love
an idea of a
catacomb-like
endless industrial nightmare it's
fantastic i think that was really good
and
functionally it's basically like a demo
but hey
there's a lot going on here and i can't
wait for chapter two so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below
and as always i will see you in the next
video
bye-bye
[Music]